well welcome welcome to your mom's house
[Music]
yeah it is a very nice jacket
thank you I you asked me out well how
much do you think a jacket like this
cost tom 500 bucks wrong $30.00
it's cool it's like I'm cheap II H&M II
dragon that's where I get all my stuff
cheap that should look supply man thanks
bro 8 toast gels in my summer bomber
look at Oh Sam it looks uh it looks like
a Downton flag here like little little
tokyo gear like i'm cool and i know
where to shop stuff yeah it does you
know when I was a little afraid of Real
Talk what's up is that the the Prince
floral I was kind of afraid of looking
like a Tommy Bahama dad oh no it does
not look are you sure no it's my stepdad
used to wear Tommy Bahama all the times
with these horrible prints and I'm like
that's kind of like the little Tom
doesn't look like that I promise I'm
Cass let's do a proper show open now I'm
saying we'll get into everything show me
all the time now very exciting very
exciting stuff here we go here we go
thing your own population defense here
is another instance when you need to
give the appearance of going along with
what is happening if you're being forced
down to orally copulate your attacker
the defense is simple quit fighting and
wait for your chance then bite off his
penis hole is my aunty don't bring
anyone love into this no barman focus
there
well welcome welcome to your palms house
with Christina
[Music]
you know I'm saying this is how I feel
every time I'm forced to orally copulate
you feel like doing this to me no I just
know that I have to surrender to give it
right why why do you feel like an
attacker I'm not an attacker I'm your
spouse you're always trying to trick me
- you're like oh I'm soft I need help
and then I go down there and you're like
just kidding
that's a lobby like the dude is bite off
his penis trash yeah
Bobby is all about it Church wouldn't do
that Trish would never bite one on now
away Trish lives for the Goblin cocks
whoa that's what she loves us Trish
Karen or Trish
they both are both down
my favorite thing about both of them is
their super dad love so low self-esteem
chick yeah I know they are the best for
one for that thing for love enjoy I'm
assuming it's what I hear oh yeah I
won't give away too much about our
marital love makings but Bobby and Trish
had a rendezvous yeah I did and I was
funny cuz I wanna do with my triple DSL
UT with that one that was funny I was
good but um it's funny because I had a
saying I was trying to unbutton right
and then you were and then and then you
said something and you just were patient
with me and it was like no Bobby
wouldn't be patient yes you can't Bob II
would say yeah because you were done
buttoning like this road it's hard -
yeah and you're like I'm sorry and I
know you what would you say right now
it's okay take your time and you're like
no B Bobby oh Jesus all right rip that
thing off then fuck you like yeah you
really are you shit
ribbit tear it knows it turn it off
bitch yeah that's really funny
no that wasn't me anyways I went to the
99-cent store today yeah which for me
and Eastern Bloc er who hates spending
money that is like the jack
yeah man I forgot how cool it is there
and how much shit there is to buy for
nothing I'm not really a 99-cent guy but
one thing that is great one thing that I
have bought there before yeah it's like
cleaning supplies yes
you know sponges and yeah little
whatever Windex all that kind of
bullshit it's great crazy they sell it
there for them can i play there's so
much cool stuff there now it's gotten
really good and they have really neat
Halloween things I got really excited
looked out so much in this in the
spending department and all I heard
about growing up all you got my wife
spends money it's all she does and
you're like I got to think we're
together I was I thought and I tell you
I'm gonna tell you guys I got so excited
because I saw the Halloween aisle and it
was really good like they have really
good stuff there I was very surprised
and I actually walked through it and I
felt a pang of guilt like I shouldn't
buy this
yeah so it's kind of fancy you know and
then I walk the aisles and then I went
back and I was like you know what
Christina you can treat yourself right
here and I spent 20 whole dollars Wow on
Halloween stuff and I that's a lot of
stuff at the night that's a ton of stuff
do this for the whole house you're 20
things yeah this for you exacting over
99 cents yes so it's like 99 cents as a
starting point there are some items the
nicer ones that are a dollar ninety-nine
whoa but they're really nice you would
never know you're going to see the
Halloween decorations I got are so nice
okay okay Beyonce I didn't exactly I
think Jesus anyway I got a lot of stuff
for LJ for the airplane ride on Sunday
my mom friend of mine told me to buy I
went to ship from a 99-cent store for
him to play with on the plane you know
Lighting's mule thing I didn't get him
toys I got him like kitchenware and shit
like he likes to play with you know yep
and they had a glow-in-the-dark axe and
I probably passed it on Instagram I
thought of you immediately it's like a
little evil kid with a glow-in-the-dark
axe yeah we got that for him course like
is this not Tom seguros son right here
yeah so he could be like a little axe
murderer yeah isn't that neat that's not
for the flight though right that's of
course it's late oh really
what's a glow-in-the-dark I mean you
know figured and
why have an idea about that site I
talked about it with my shrink today and
well uh look he told me she goes but
he's going to cry during takeoff and
landing you should count on that because
their ears are very fragile at that age
yeah and you know just probably now that
that's an inevitability give him
something to suck on like a bottle right
milk gymnast bah bah and you know oh oh
and she said the crying is actually good
because that's how they unplugged their
ears through crying it'll help RAAS s so
she goes it's actually a good thing yeah
and you know I have a big fear of losing
control that's my thing I got control
issues so it's for me the baby crying
like that on and I also I'm afraid of
judgement of other people horses it's
not so much the freak out because he's
freaked out in public before but it's
that it's an unclosed yeah much it's
heightened you know and we're going to
ruin other people's flight that's my
fear yeah and then looking at me like
this dumbfuck woman doesn't know how to
take care of her kid yeah I have the
same fears yeah the way what's your
biggest I don't know I've been talking
to friends one of my friends was like
well you know your kid's going to cry
and you can't worry about that stuff
people people know that kids cry yeah
and they've been around kids before and
you know they're irritated by it that's
just part of it I mean you do your best
obviously to try to to get over it but
yeah I have total anxiety about it total
and I remember it's similar to anxiety
and I'm also very like sensitive to that
so those other people being like oh my
god no in a restaurant if he bangs a
fork against the table you know I'll
grab him doing hey like I don't want to
bother other people yeah I'm the same I
had the same panic the first time I flew
a thief back in the day yeah that I did
too I was super nervous so scary
I would relax when I finally like put it
under the seat and he shell and I was
like and then I'll get anxiety of
presentations I can I get out like just
be careful under yeah see it is a dog
okay yeah you know what apologetic but
you know what that is I mean for me
anyways and it's my perfectionism yeah
or if I'm not a perfect I'm not perfect
to being a mom that I'm a piece of shit
that's my big
they're like that it means that I'm a
bad person if no it could help you get
over that second son dude's dick not
some dude
my friend Kevin you blow him you'll feel
better
who's Kevin I don't know this guy
the guy's our son's real dad what you
don't think LJ is your son I have
thoughts I've done what part of that
what part of him you know you know don't
you think resembles you or no no
sometimes I look it I'm like was your
bio dad okay Bob hey
this will cause shock and definitely end
any thoughts about rape definitely oh
that's terrifying that is a crazy thing
like his haircut bowling in that yeah
that's definitely a tease he's a super
dad let's take another look at this
defense oh yeah it's telling you to
Saget you're pushing back does everyone
know looking well if you want to survive
you'll consider this yeah bench
technique good girl
daddy they're cucumber yeah or you had a
real bloody darkness
yeah really green dark dick Wow make
sure they're biting it is all this will
cause shock and definitely end any
thoughts about rape
hell yeah definitely wrote that but they
deserve an award yeah he ain't raping
now there you go right now dick bet off
your dicks off didn't have that is a
really good tactic I mean if I were if I
had to wherewithal to do it I definitely
would in that situation
I voted in your mind right the fuck out
i dick dude yeah rip his fucking nuts
off too yeah
I wonder if fuck him right in the dick
if he would then have a case against you
you know like I was yeah I was going for
it but like she'd have to burn it off oh
I bet it off yeah fucking yeah yeah
nothing sounds worse than a dick bite
now and then you have the dig blood in
your mouth and everything it's not good
but did i right
and I also wonder if my veneers can
handle that kind of a bike oh right I
mean I can't even bite an apple you'd
have a hell of a dental update yeah and
your dentist would flip like what
happened like I bit this dude's dick off
what
yeah put this guy's dick in my mouth and
I bit it off yeah yet pictures of show
them and he's just like yeah let me
think you know what's on the house to me
don't worry about anything all night oh
geez do you think a lot of women forced
men to go down on them you think that's
an epidemic no I don't think so but it
definitely has happened and continues to
happen there's just not a lot you can
really do like it you can we buy her
vagina you guys think about there's
probably some relationships out there
where the woman is a bully and even less
where the woman is stronger yeah but it
definitely happened of course it happens
which is amazing to think about as a guy
because it's almost inconceivable to
most guys right but it happens you know
of course yeah
she's like you better do this I'm gonna
eat my pussy fucking idiot and he's like
I wanna do it like this right but then
looking he did I guess he can try to
bite her a bad job all right but no he's
probably so saying you could bite you
could bite down there yeah you could oh
that was how fast he bit his balls I
think that was hurt worse yeah I think a
ball bite might be more effective than a
dick whitey yeah ball bite would just
shut down the whole system your whole
body was just shut down you know what I
would do okay I would yeah I would give
it and then I would give them and I
might get my dick bite and a ball Pole
ah that's the same time and then hey I
can feel good I'd like that
I wouldn't like the dick by it behaving
like that ball feel a tug feels good
live as I hug what if it's a full pole I
got yeah but even the aggressive fucking
pole no no I'll be like you like your
balls lick and then you go under and be
like ah and then yeah hi you bite one of
those balls that's oh okay then all
thoughts of rape are gone yeah
true right now it all thoughts of rape
are gone yeah he should be teaching her
the ball bite not just a dick bite why
are we making new video nothing wrong
with that offer to lick his balls and
then when you go in for the lady forces
his penis in your mouth stop him and say
do you like having your balls like then
place his balls
all right in your mouth spit a bunch on
them so he thinks your game yeah and
then take a big bite
ha ha ha it's nasty we can make that
video yeah where are you some peaches
peaches too you know they had a cucumber
yeah all right yeah simulate yeah yeah
do you like your balls licked your
attacker will pause yeah wait a minute
matter of fact I've never had that done
before you do it real quick
stupid rapist stupid dumb rapers how
about this this guy's pretty much a
rapist say yoshi imma give me like is
this guy talking about no but I mean
it's like I'm a subway and he tells this
guy let me see I didn't American man oh
he was in Singapore his female friend
filmed this incident as the Asian man
reportedly kept asking for sex yeah I
mean so this older guys on the subway
and he's like you are gay are you gay
yeah I'm talking to him I don't fucking
- you really oh this is my
they're being very no no no she's no no
I'm your friend
oh yeah no I went to the pocket black I
don't know who you are I want you to hug
me to my wall now very different
approach and also demanding to be fucked
it yeah that's also really interesting
because you're being aggressive but
you're asking for the submissive roles
right I feel like I missed the
introduction here the introduction was
he he was just like yo i'ma give me good
thing about I see you on Facebook yeah
you're gay I'm gay too and he's like I'm
talking to you bitch talking to him huh
and she and then the boat the guy goes
that's my friend you could she see this
guy goes it's not your friend I'm your
friend he's like no no thanks I want you
to fuck me in my ass
yeah I'm talking to him I don't look
into you okay really
oh this is my friend you're being very
Rizal no no she's gonna fight I'm your
friend no Anna I want you to fuck me to
like I don't know who you are and I'm
not I want you talking to my whoa I feel
like he just learned these phrases for
his you know his pleasure
basically he doesn't speak good English
but he's like how do I say this oh yeah
I want you to fuck me tonight pretty
good pretty good at it how did you see
I'm obviously not yes you are you're
game play by anybody I want you to hug
people oh please don't touch me again
boy he's gonna let it go we can touch
you hey you're banned ago I'm here now
yeah he should definitely dick fight
this old guy I know or do the ball
licking approach yeah he should be like
the guy should be like you want me to I
wanted to fuck him tonight he should go
do you like having your balls like
anything I think what yeah I do look man
I'm done and then he goes ah legs odd
balls for like for like 20 30 minutes
and then anything all right wait how you
mean he's sharpening his knife for that
long well you got to make it you gotta
you can't have him suspect you're going
to do some notes you got to kind of get
into it for a long time here bald like
that well I mean he's trying to convince
them right
I'm not going to do it like I'm game
that's how you lure him in you spit on
his dick in his balls like 25 35 45
minutes right that's what I would do and
then when he's like really in the
euphoria of it then you bite his balls
oh so you really you're really rope it
up yeah but you gotta blow them and lick
his balls for like an hour for the
method or yes to work this is my
approach that's how I train women all
the time in this this is my very system
that calm I don't like where this is
going what do you mean this is
problematic you're making fun of rape no
no no no no no no wait a minute I'm
talking about a defense haha fence
system that I've developed over a year
how are you like the sharpening the
knife through yeah I teach this class
where I and I have women practice you
know on me I go just just put this in
your mouth for like 30 to 40 minutes and
uh-huh and then when I least suspect it
just show me your finger and that'll be
that'll be a signal that you're right or
she has to put her finger in your bum
hole yep and then that is surprised too
that's another get away from me
sometimes it'll happen is I'll come to
turrent during that time period and then
I go now we got to start over but you
know we're getting there it's just it's
a matter of practice you know practice
practice ready 50/50 every time I see
Asian guys now I always assume they're
showing their knives oh like oh we went
to a sushi bar yesterday in Little Tokyo
turn on Ben grounds around there and all
the sushi chefs say I just imagine them
sharpening their knives before their
shift you know you're do you think he's
Reverend is like this morning like 100
percent good I'm so stupid I didn't do
all Asian men do that now crazy we're
yeah rah rah all of them because of that
one guy he really is a mentor I know
okay I know can I become racist now oh
so racist you're just assuming that all
these guys come hard yeah you know they
Envisat
we come I think Jimmy is ready advisable
come they're contracting their time and
if they're not circumscribe
circumstances well guys our
circumstances and then they came back
and you just Jack your dick so many
people by the way I never thought this
but a lot of people messaged when I
tweeted out the link to that video
they're like this guy's mentally ill
course most people are that we Arab yeah
well a mental illness video shows come
on no it's not yes are you crazy come to
your mom's out no thanks funny but he's
not crazy yeah he's a very deliberate
the same way I do my self-defense class
alright you're crazy okay wonderful
oh no me I did not it doesn't mean well
this lady is trying to tell him well I
believe she put her hands on him like
that not that she's wrong right just
that that's a bold move yeah but you're
right you're absolutely right
however to be clear so we the audience
understands it's listening yeah another
third party came in a woman American
woman came in and put her hands on the
asian man and like told him to calm down
and get back right but see in our world
and in female world a gay man it is
equal to a woman oh we don't think of
them as dudes I think they're just
they're girls like us they're changing
the girls that is so offensive I know
it's true though I'm gonna weep no but
don't know what I mean but see that guy
actually took to it okay he was like
look you said I was giving a sack of her
that em home but I can't believe he
didn't kiss her back he was touching the
other people yeah it's not cool why
would you she demand sex from another
niggas be on the train length is not yo
she could be him older Yoshi
although yo she's like 50 now and he
looks pleased 20 it's horri how's that
possible so lucky I think though
he looks really good
sorry sorry I'm going touchable yeah I
know
okay this is murder is on my game yeah
so just to be clear now the Asian man is
saying there's no laws here
anyone can touch anybody which I doubt
is true in Singapore of all places that
is super strict and then he's just like
he's a gay imma game did this happen to
you when you were in Singapore no no no
you know I do like about the older gays
like this like that he really does put
it out there the flag is flying he's
like look man I want to fun but at this
age I applaud that you should down like
that I know I agree go do it
I don't like to eat harassing this this
dude I don't think that's from the
father but let's see if you actually mr.
Roper gets amazing mr. row close the
deal here
Jackie shoe I was teaching out my smile
what's your fucking face off yeah
fucking you like a lot
one guy Daniel oh he's a typicai he
justifies what do you want oh my god
whoa whoa what if he knows the world is
fucking never who connected there did he
connect with the guy yeah yet he had the
guy that he's trying to get to fuck him
Wow he slapped that guy's face I think
yeah he's holding his face like that guy
just hit me what a dickhead fuck this I
want to focus like my is the sexual
assault yeah episode what's going on
different ways it comes together
why you talking like what what's with
all the assault clip now you just say I
want where as our other guys but we my
my Amanda yeah right one is a humble
request the other one is a demanding
yeah thank you sure gave you yeah you're
out here up you fucking gay fucking gay
yes you are you again he just told that
dude he was that guy didn't say anything
to him I guess I get our thing is real
man but who knows if that guy really was
who knows yeah I don't know who my
female friend companion you know yeah
well I guess you didn't say this is like
my boyfriend my husband still like I was
crazy yeah so man no good luck to him
babe
hope things work out so anyway we were
really Oh yesterday and we met a mommy
on the street that was fun yeah that was
pretty good I was like hey mommy's like
whoa walking across this yeah we tried
to go to an awesome sushi joint we ended
up back at another good one but yeah
there was a line any line fuck all that
I'm over lines for restaurants this is
America man this ain't Russia I'm not
doing that anymore yeah I wait no
fucking bread lines I don't care what it
is man there's all these uh you know
what is it like Franklin's barbecue in
Austin or like Hattie's and in a
Ashville and every time i go there like
you got to go this place and then
there's like an hour way nightlight and
I'm like we'll go somewhere else but
this is awesome like ya know it's not
that awesome sanely happen Philly I went
to some cheesesteak place and it wasn't
the two big ones it wasn't Geno's or the
one whatever it is across the street and
the same thing it's like I waited like
45 minutes or an hour to get a
cheesesteak and then my friend was like
how is it I'm like it's a good
cheesesteak I mean it tastes like a good
one well what it tastes better if you're
now have to wait in line for 45 of
course of course man I don't know and
I'm just not into it I'm not into it
either I don't have that kind of time or
patience for waiting for the nation's
for it
I just go somewhere and we went down the
street something I can do to skip this
line no okay I'll go somewhere else well
they always lie to you too and they're
like oh it goes by fast put your name no
it never does when you're standing here
I know as soon as I saw that going
outside for that for lunch that blaze I
was like go fuck yourself there man fuck
out of here with that shit get the fuck
where did we see a douchebag a hedge
fund guy that was there no but where do
we see him again at the store where I
bought that shirt for little James were
he was walking out and we know that was
starbucks bar sucks we took a pee there
yes took a break yeah that yeah there so
Flanders like a group of the cast of
billions like dude US Coast douchebags
yeah like white shoes I like it starting
to get that sadness that a series ending
second and others like five six episodes
left them a real hmm now did they are
they making a season 3 or is I don't
know worrying about it let's see let's
see if a billion billion billions let's
see if there's a season three announced
confirmed yes it'll air next year though
Oh mother offer but when when next year
doesn't say why did it take so long to
make my favorite TV shows I wish is here
now this furthers my argument for
starting a show well after it it's uh
yeah and then you can binge the ten
seasons I hear like I'm into The
Sopranos dude yeah I like it fucking
like it like that's a zombie show I'm on
board yeah we talk about a game
yeah but what we saw at the sushi bar
was interesting we saw a lot of hungry
tits out and about yes no bra no bra was
French yeah Ted he's just out yeah just
little titties dying to eat Barry said
they were just licking their lips like
Jia something for me and I tried to put
my chopsticks up to her tits and say
give me give it a little piece stupid it
was like no F you didn't when I can but
she was a French girl so that's kind of
I love you in French I don't wear bra
even though we invented lose you lay
another one so weird the euros do that
they like their tits to jiggle around
but only if you got small hungry tips
can you do coughing you can't go braless
when you got big quadruple D slut wife
tits like mine there's no fucking way
well you just look then you look crazy
because my hanger is old hangers out
yeah you look real crazy yeah cuz they
move a lot more than you know those
little French did to do of course um
let's see
so if you're if you're listening the
moment this comes out
we are in breath Paul's Beach tonight
that's right we're doing the podcast
live Tomcat Palm Beach County if you're
here for our date come see us we're at
the breath Falls Beach improv we're
doing a live podcast and we're going to
do a course of meet and greet with
everybody afterwards we'll be hanging
out come see us come say hi I might have
a glass of chardonnay oh my okay it's
humiliation are listening I also would
love to tell you that I have a huge leg
of my tour coming up I'm gonna rub rub
rub in Lincoln Nebraska Midwest City
Oklahoma and Springfield Missouri
that's my lead-up week to my special
taping week which I will start September
13th in Brea September 14 at the Oakland
excuse me the Fox Theatre in Oakland
California and then I'm shooting two
shows in Denver Malmberg Colorado at the
Paramount September 16th I couldn't be
more excited from there
the tour continues I have a bunch of
cities at Tom Segura calm slash tour
please check out the site and you can
see them coming to everywhere from
Albany to Portland Maine Toronto Ann
Arbor Indy st. lous tips farts go
San Antonio Austin keeps going New York
City Buffalo LA fnix Mar flow and we're
doing another podcast live in Irvine
sperm vine October the 8th Irvine
California at the improv tickets did not
transfer if you had them before so you
have to get new ones gene what was the
title we had for your special at Denver
coming on you Denver I don't know man
yesterday we came up with a writ of few
mile hike um dot kick okay okay all
right
September 22nd 23rd st. Luke's hits
Missouri at the helium comedy club
October 3rd Nashville what is Nashville
Northville Nashville - Ville Tennessee
Zanies comedy club October 4th
Charlotte North Carolina as you say as
if that's a real thing real comedy zone
and then with you October 8th at ymh
wives and sperm vine yeah very exciting
area maids excite guys check out that's
deep bro as well I take listener emails
this week a girl wrote in asking whether
or not she should reveal that her cousin
is actually her biological sister whoa
Jerry Springer stuff pretty exciting and
her cousin is her biological sister and
the cousin doesn't know it they don't
know it no one person knows it's her
mother I don't see much I know it's
awesome all right well there you go
that's deep bro tell you go check it out
yeah uh yeah that's it right that's all
you have for now you're one to always
boast and brag about your h2o
consumption meanwhile you you tear those
down who hydrate in a different manner
science has something to say to you in a
study that sure to wake you up new
research says coffee won't dehydrate you
in fact researchers from Birmingham
University say first you have to the
drink our Jim I'm reading his water Oh
bullshit
listen I don't know what kind of fake
news propaganda this is news breaker
whatever that is I erratic effective
caffeine is balanced by the amount of
water in the drink something that wasn't
taken into account the last time I think
I am a nun in 1928 Jesus now the current
study compared man you drank four months
of coffee versus four mugs of water for
three days
while eating the same food the result a
guilt-free cup of morning Joe for the
rest of us
Wow whatever just still drink water of
course propaganda about 1.6 billion cups
of coffee are consumed worldwide every
day this study is sure to please the
masses but researchers still suggest
balancing each cup with a glass of water
see them why do they still why would
they still suggest that they have to
watch their bags
it's amazing exactly in trouble because
they know this is not conclusive this is
not a conclusive study they're still
saying drink water in addition to
otherwise they would just sell you
bottles a copy like this and they and
then may give marathon runners bottles
of coffee so there you go it's fine you
can drink your coffee I'm thirsty when I
drink coffee though I think it's because
you're retarded and ah then that happens
where it goes down weird and then you're
thirsty a lot of that is because your
chromosomes are all weighted let's go
through some special some title specials
for you I go retarded oh my god where my
teeth are still yellow my teeth are
still yellow that's a good one write it
down not personality chance hmm how
about retarded comic I like that yeah
how about we had some great ones
yesterday no I know that's how it goes I
just suck on it Denver come come come on
my suck or something like that
mmm come on my balls balls full of cum
yeah now that's a catchy title yeah um
let's see we had some great ones we do
jokes forget it just forget this you
forget all if you forget them all too
though I know I forget them let's do
some new what are you leaning towards
come beard no what what rub rub rub
yeah I like that one sharpening the
knife just Glasson
just Glasson that's a good title I know
doesn't matter that my special my hours
not about that like comedy titles you
want those to word and three word titles
yeah no those are the ones too those are
the best one plus it's a shout-out to
all your mom out to the podcast it's a
that's great ki art for that like the
cover and stuff it like a hold
particularly and like kind of oily
glasses stupid and but other think it
can be stupid it's a stand-up special
yeah supposed to be silly
yeah I mean you could call it sharpening
the knife I like that too yeah that's
actually a really good its but you know
it's obviously a joke I mean and you
could take that seriously like I'm
sharpening my joke let it play yeah it's
like I'm killing it yeah it's silly yeah
but I mean jokingly sharpening the knife
is funny I think you sure entitle and I
am sharpening the knife
you know metaphorically minimum right so
you rub rub rub about jokes for mu soup
mm-hmm what about fuck me in my ass hey
that's a title dog cigarette will be my
Edmonds favorite what about Tom Segura
and then the title is Tom or black
that's good you get that then you get
different audience the demographics
changes a little bit
yeah how about how about 50 inches press
9 inches in prime 9 images press 9
inches and yeah
how does my asshole smell oh that's a
good title mail that how does my asshole
smell huh that's what the hot in there
uh not all Nazis are bad thought they
would then what about the other side
guys that could be that could be a title
that's a funny time all Nazis are bad
yeah
how about some neo-nazis it's nifty
Nazis listen like that like how about
this also Nazis Tom Segura silly Nazi
silly Nazi that's a pretty funny time
yeah yeah mmm that's just a fun one
they're tickling what I'd say Hitler hey
Heller yeah I mean that's a whole new
you're really doing
really happy fasting the net for the
audience the conversation would go with
the presence breaking it down so here's
what I want to do like no no you don't
get it it's like a shadow job you don't
get it all aggressive and you're like
it's not really about Hitler it's about
as a girl the video my way back you guys
are doing good how about I like that
you're doing you're doing good
well I wanted to call mine good job and
they were up they wouldn't go for that
you guys are doing good are you guys are
doing good yeah you're doing good yeah
yeah you did well Oh about this right
this Tom Segura
what's your pronoun oh that's amazing
yeah I like what's your pronoun let's
see that would work better for you
what's your foot ah
oh yeah cuz I have non-binary stuff how
many a lot of nasty emails on me
definitely I don't think you're ready
for it I have no idea I'm really gonna
oh man
tell me always Matthew - Thank You Nancy
about nasty as hell how about we run the
industry now running the industry huh
you like that that's good for you yeah
you like that kind of you know yeah
sassy lingo yeah that's good
we're gonna keep the motherfuckers out
those other fuckers our trap 99 build
that wall build that wall build that
wall there you go God there you go I'd
be the last special I ever had oh my god
could you imagine that Wow my life yeah
boy I'm telling you I actually this is a
good title just classic just class is a
great title yeah I love you guys Glasson
write in and let us know if you think
that's a good time we should put up a
poll actually yes yes how about class
late last yeah
what about it's not sexual or it's just
like the gays just like the gay how
about it's only smells it's only smells
that's actually really good room yeah
hmm I don't know about would you marry
your mom would you marry your mom would
you ever date your mom ask them will you
ever date your mom a good title I would
date my mom that's my title I asked I
asked it's just like the gays for me for
far not actually a definitely good
comedy title for real is you know what
I'm saying you know what I'm doing
yeah that's a good time come eat oh
you're talking and it has to be a play
on it though yeah like you know I don't
know what the play is but it can't just
be able talk about marketing remember
that was the best one missed I was in
here and you played for each she's like
you always do the best you make fun of
black men but we know she goes I love
your invitation yes your invitation it's
like I got a sudden vision is yeah yeah
so disrespectful oh my gob strong I'll
go roller comes frog how about ooh I got
another a good one are you ready for it
yeah okay hold on this is a I don't see
it this would be so good luck you guys
are doing I think it's rub rub rub rub
rub rub
no I think it's just glassing are you
feel me on timeout you know is that I
feel me you know tell me if you know I'm
saying that's a that's a good one funny
yeah oh here it is ready yeah this is
the title comes up on your screen Tom
Segura when I am the king of in promise
for freedom I sense on the King an
improv King of improv I like that about
the king of stand-up the king of yeah
see I could be the king of combat and
there's a king to come me yeah awesome
title so it's a brat and it's so brash
and I get so much hate people like a
snap of leaf is so crazy how do you
think we actually have to pause for a
moment
press pause with the press pause with
our two cat laws and do a business call
yeah do our little
business call we'll be right back well
you won't even know I don't know I'm
saying we'll be right back welcome back
we're back as well in 77 some
interesting emails came in a drooper our
hot farts smellier oh wow
nae mam ajam TV last night came across a
question that needs immediate attention
I was on the couch X bi non-binary
spouse when I had to FA RT upon release
I noticed the startingly hot nature of
the gas and happened to be particularly
smelly and I pondered what the
connection of heat to smell is how far
to come out hot more smelly yeah yeah
and what causes the heat sensation Wow
and you had to come to Ryan and mommy to
get to the bottom of this I will see you
at wet balls Beach with a live show I
called ahead to make sure they have
moose soup ready hey please well
interesting question and I feel like
medically we need to I think we need to
reach out to a professional to get real
guidance on that but I definitely have
had that thought like wow this is hot
and it doesn't smell good no and I think
I think you're right that the ha starts
do tend to be smellier yeah and I think
it has something to do with the
molecules being heated up si RP it's you
know why okay think about it when you
cook food in the microwave the molecules
bounce around and the smell emanates
right because of the heat but why is it
hot why is it coming out of you right
now that's another question that I mean
why are there hot fart no I feel like
this is one of the great life aren't you
great mysteries of life like do twins
have identical dicks this is one of
those questions yeah why are they hotter
I don't know
so far on the identical dicks we've kind
of come to the conclusion that identical
twins seem to have identical dicks but
fraternal twins don't necessary which
makes sense yeah oh yes yes we went back
to this board reading
yeah so let's go down the list of things
that give you hot far it's number one
broccoli a dried apricots give me hot
farts ethnic
kimchee now you know what they have in
common what high fiber content there you
go bell peppers high fiber fiber makes
it hotter now but why does fiber
translate to heat in your bum hole it's
a great question why is it define I
don't know these are there's a lot of
mysteries out there that yeah I don't
know we got a puppy okay so if you're a
medical professional let us know why do
we birds are high why are farts
sometimes hot why are heart hot farts
familiar well we just I know why they're
smelly er because they're hot and
therefore the molecules are bouncing
around that's your theory you said I
know that's what creates smell you're
saying you don't know that probably my
theory
wait I'm like let's get it confirmed
seventh-grade science knowledge let's
get it confirmed God man okay I never
and isn't that amazing you go through
your whole life just accepting that as a
given and then one day somebody just
challenges your whole way of being you
feel that heat come on you're like oh
man if you're in public a look around
like all this is going to hit somebody
ya know before you know before when that
when that gas is cooking when it's
really on those on like oh yeah he's
going to stink like yesterday I was
eating a bowl of my own soup not mousse
soup just veggie soup yeah and I thought
I shouldn't have the second Bowl because
it's going to make a lot of hot farts
and I didn't want to punish you in bed
and then there's like you know with
noisy ones it's here there you go yeah
this is loud maybe and then you go oh
nothing could go either way to go either
way sometimes I'll even let out a fart
during a massage even if I have a finger
control if the control is there yeah
because I know like it can't smell that
like that bad really you haven't I'm Sam
but sometimes can't you feel that this
one would smell if I let it out yes
those are the hot ones you know they're
hot before they even come out till you
like it's gonna be hot yeah sometimes
you go that'll be amazing yeah did you
feel the gurgles
you know the cramping that goes with it
yes dear mommy's in recent packages
playing the clip of the mother and son
who were dating this behavior could be
explained by genetic sexual attraction
yeah GSA is and
overwhelming sexual attraction that may
develop between close blood relatives
who first meet as adults and that could
very well happen could have been what
happened to those two I had that that
thing of like seemed like they didn't
grow up together correct she didn't
raise him she may have birthed him but
didn't raise a college friend of mine
was adopted as a baby after college he
sought out her birth family and found
her mother and two brothers during
counseling she was warned about genetic
sexual attraction his dog that it occurs
because the normal sibling parental
bonding doesn't occur during childhood
supposedly it's rare I'm beginning to
wonder if then I think that's a really
interesting email absolutely so what's
happening is like because of the lack of
that bonding between siblings and/or
parents something happens when you meet
them for the first time as adults yeah
and you you're you're trying to you know
figure out or let the bonding occur and
it turns into it it's sexual energy
because it's not it's not dispersed
naturally through raising that our stuff
you know what I read today my shrinks
office is why people are attracted but
it is just like the gays yeah like
sexual partners not related people yeah
and they say that you're attracted to
people that look like you really yeah
like it's unconscious where they have
similar features and if you look at the
two of us both of us have big lips I
have beautiful eyes yours are kind of
bulging like feets but we have similar
you know the dark baggy under-eyes
circles and I mean our kid looks
you have a nice penis you penis is
enormous like yeah they say that you
look for people that look similar to you
but there's a lot of people that don't
swing it did I sit down
yeah yeah of course of course there are
yeah of course yeah but that's gosh I
wonder about that do you think we saw
each other out for that unconscious I
think you connect sexually with people
too when like in a more deep way not
obviously like just a one-night stand
way but when you're attracted to
somebody that you shared psychological
things with oh yeah I think it's it's a
total meshing of our unconscious
bullshit yeah our issues definitely all
that's all mommy did that I see clearly
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah definitely
yeah you and I that's why we work well
together I think it really is just like
a case we really we have such a good
unconscious pairing yeah it's our issues
that kind of meld together nicely you
know when it comes to dad Boehner's a
lot of people we pointed out that
there's two types of dad boners there's
there's the real the true dad boner
who's excited for something and not
excitable yeah then we call it the
justified dad boner and that is somebody
who's super excited about something but
there's reason to be and that one is is
a is is there's more reason to celebrate
and we shouldn't you know those are the
ones that we not along to like yeah I
see why you're this excited we have one
of those today it is a dad boner for
sure justified but it's justified his
boners is there for a reason and I would
be this excited to check out what this
boner does he's he's doing like frisbee
golf and a really big doll
yeah I'm throwing a frisbee on a horse
trying to get to a target okay but he's
really I mean this is I don't know far
away you would say people love that
frisbee shit that I don't know you sure
that's it look at this look how far the
white people are is ready there Phil
it's fucking eighty yards away I've
gotten so far look at it that's a real
fuck that was I to do yeah he's really
that was a really good throw
I mean look how far away that is I know
why people love playing frisbee don't
think yeah they have like Ultimate
Frisbee leagues and dumb shit like that
around fucking frisbee give white people
too much time on their hands you know
they either March with the tiki torches
or they throw a frisbee right you got to
keep white people occupied
I'm real excited idle hands but I
understand that level except mean that
is that was good look at lookup for
Windows feels like it's a goddamn
football field he imagined like how much
better it is that it's recorded that guy
otherwise just like remember when I did
that and do like well like whatever dad
did you really do it what yeah I didn't
know people even did this yeah this is
so weird
the frisbee golf yeah cuz the fucking
course like two of the most boring
sports put together and one thing I know
I'm trying I wish I could get into golf
it just takes too long to play it's like
a four-hour commitment half your fucking
day a lot of times how do people have
time for golf I want to have I don't
know I sighs about about being in the
culture of it just because I feel like
it's it be it's fun way to unwind it's a
hanging out basically is what it is yeah
you're hanging out with your friends yes
I don't know if I could get into the
dough I did it 20 years ago I played
regularly for one summer after my
freshman year in college my parents
lived on a golf course so I came home I
had a job where I could set my own hours
so I would just I just took up golf and
I was taking lessons and I was playing
he's playing pretty regularly and I
enjoyed it
you are you good at it I got to I got to
respectable I got to the point where my
great fear it's almost like flying with
the with our son was that when I was
when I was playing before that and when
I was on the driving range I was
terrible and I was embarrassed to join a
like a twosome of the collar or foursome
like a group to play golf and then I
played so much that summer that by like
mid summer I was I could play a
respectable round meaning like you know
I could hit the ball without it hooking
or shanking and and and I were going for
feet instead of you know 100 yards so I
just got I got a I mean I was not good
but I was enough I was
enough to join a game of golf and play
and and you're again there yeah yeah but
then I went back to college and I
remember I didn't play for like six
months or something and then somebody
was like don't play golf today I go sure
we went out there and man I shit the bed
so bad and it just it was a discouraging
it was just you know yeah oh I suck at
this I said well it's an older kind of
older guys I mean it's definitely bigger
for sure amongst older guys but it is
like a you know the thing that I like
about golf is that it takes you to
destinations in other words you'll end
up checking out places you wouldn't
because yeah as a golf as a destination
and it's the hang it's like I could call
somebody up we doing today let's go play
golf and write you a rose you go there
and bro down now is there any athletic
ability required to play golf can you
stand right that's what I'm saying those
guys don't really look good well it's
not a working out unless you're Tiger
yeah no I mean yes not you can be a
piece of shit give me a fat fuck like
bowling too it doesn't require do you
have that job that joke about it what is
it the Triple Crown of lazy yeah darts
bowling and golf yeah yeah bowling I
forget and you can be a fat fucking
still be in that you can yeah yeah no I
wouldn't do it's not like a sport that
I'm hanging up to stay in shape it was
huge yeah I think that's the problem
that's it I mean even theoretically with
golf for me is that it requires no
physical ability it's a huge time-suck
you're on the Sun get you fucking burned
expensive it's the reason that it is not
for me um the people chase the dragon
though is that is what happens is it's
very it's difficult right takes an
incredible amount of skill and so you
have a good shot or a good hole yeah
then you go oh that was fucking awesome
like I had a birdie now I went under par
I I did really well that and then that
feel that's the feeling you're chasing
great right doing well I'll
like that I like miniature golf it's
also very challenging yes that's can be
yeah it's fun yeah that's good yeah I
don't think you would like actual golf
I've only ever know I've never played I
would never you never know you actually
never you could go out into a driving
range have somebody show you how to do
it and then you could just you could be
somebody that has like a natural skill
yeah you could yeah I doubtful okay no
it's definitely doubtful I've got hold
on I'm deaf in one ear here yeah sure
brace yourself fix it
fix it let's see hello hello
no still fuck octa no sofa cactus weird
it just happened when we came back from
our call it's definitely not here it's
yeah it's in the can yeah it's well fix
it later it's fine for now
well I don't know will I pick up golf I
don't know maybe when you're all I mean
I get when you're old then you got if
you're retired perfect yeah not of a
time hang out with your friends you
don't need to have a lot of ability it's
definitely an older man's gentlemen
gentlemen gentlemen
yeah nice bola gentlemen as I did
another great blind question came in I
love these please I love these so much
I know Anna Janice and by the way thank
you for all the feedback people have
been emailing us about our deaf and
blind questions and so fascinating
before our fascinated by it including us
as a reminder if you have a question and
answer a clip a song always email the
gmail account it is your mom's podcast
at gmail.com don't send it on Facebook
don't send it to any other address send
it to the gmail account
your mom's podcast at gmail.com and as
always thank you for messaging us with
content this clips with all that you can
go to your mom's house podcast at sorry
your mom's house podcast.com if you want
to check out the site has YouTube links
links to all the download has a link to
the store
we have a bunch of really cool shirts
merch things that are signed check that
out and thank you as always for your
support so here is the question you have
trouble with that one - yeah I can hear
it crackling on the right it's
something's wrong and someone doing one
year and I switched headphones - so
we're the grayed out the interval what
do blind people masturbate - oh my god
you've been listening to your
educational podcast for quite a while
now and I really appreciate you tackling
all these hot button issues the major
networks are afraid to touch on the
topic of blind people I couldn't help
but wonder about their porn preferences
do blind people just listen to the audio
why they pound off and/or DJ the beam I
know they make movies and TV with audio
description for the blind that describes
what is happening overtop of the audio
do they make porn for the blind to
describe what is happening the scene
also I don't know anyone that watches
the full scene it doesn't just skip
around to the good parts how do blind
people skip to just the bits they want
to hear i anxious ly await your answer
thank you for keeping me in the know
every Wednesday Tyler from Cincinnati
really great question Tyler first of all
we actually did play mm-hmm a blind
Lauren for the blind so somebody
describes it to the blind person but
he's saying how to how do they skip
ahead I mean I guess that's just what
they do I feel like you did something to
me now really yeah
yeah I gotta stop this hi Evie okay now
it's back to normal what just happened I
don't know no well I'm deaf and one ear
you're definitely here okay did you try
moving your mic cable mm-hm because when
I don't like it I think that how would I
move it I don't know if I move mine and
pop back in Wow
okay I'll figure it out later I can
surprise um let's see
I feel like did we can I tell you one
thing that our trainer told me that is
very it's been upsetting me she says she
has a friend who has the toe toe why
fled yeah but her model flushes itself
when she told me they have a toilet that
flushes for them I felt like we were the
poorest people ever yeah I know we don't
have that I feel like a peasant now so
the toilet flushes by itself yes that's
not what we have no I have to flush and
I feel like I'm a poor person why don't
we have that have you done today what
did you do to this why did you do that I
did nothing you did I did nothing to
your did goddamnit what's wrong now I'm
hearing a weird shit now that you keep
fucking with the headphone jack Bob you
said you are how is that abusive so mean
how does that mean they definitely gay
gay gay gay it was probably very
accurate but you're not here the goonies
lady right now ah man you room
I know it's mines crackling - I didn't
ruin all right so let's see if this is a
something that could play porn for the
blind no no this is a real one or not to
engage in various sexual scenarios flash
in quick succession yeah
December dictation you're kneeling on
the green gray shag carpet one onto his
thighs giving him a rapid blowjob hey
you guy think kisses the head of his
penis as he rubs it along her left
breast
he's now standing over her as she lays
on the cushions on the dark green couch
holding up yeah slowly goes between on
so it's porn for the blind I guess
that's it how do you fast-forward
through that you just fast-forward
yeah you just scroll forward and then
usually what's going on now you know
doing them both of them
she's filming herself so my guys coming
on her ass there you go that's what I
wanted I mean that's it that's exactly
what we're talking about right Scrolls
forward what's that you know so good job
good job making that porn but I guess
that is you know that is real porn for
yeah I guess so
these are imaginations yeah otherwise
you just listen to the you know ruins
port aliza porn music yeah I think what
ruins porn for me too is all the
scenarios and the bill that like just go
to the bag you like that gonzo just get
in I mean I'm not gonna watch plot and I
got it all watch no no sometimes don't
care you don't like oh shit I miss the
bus no I mean it's not like I'm I'm
really pleased with myself when I'm
doing that so if I just get in and get
out wait you're up selling yourself or
just checking it out well I'm not I'm
not in a good place if I'm you know what
I mean Wow really that desert that's
really harsh though on yourself is it I
think so to be like I'm not in a good
place
well I guess I just want to get in and
get out I'm not really looking to spend
a lot of time in that neighborhood how
much time did you try to spend there
when you do go this I don't know I don't
time myself but I definitely don't want
to like lounge and put my feet up and
really in in the terror
I thought that there was the only way to
do that is get comfortable you have your
drink yes I'm to eat you're like you
know let's get so I get through 30 of
these and yeah like the most I don't
have that kind of time I know I don't do
that okay I'm not interested and usually
it's such a vulgar area you know the
neighborhood is so dark no those are
like creampie double-fist anal finally I
don't want any of that any normal where
is like the normal section this normal
section shut that shit down I don't want
to see that at all I want to see you
know what do you like prolapse colons
fix dicks
stuff that's just crazy yeah yeah it's
too crazy that's what I'm saying I think
it's not that I'm so ashamed myself more
so that the neighbor it's so crazy just
to find like a relatively tame clip yeah
do you know what I mean yeah I'm not
into the sixth guy prolapse : right anal
fisting double sock Pete you know what's
wrong with you it's just normal stuff is
exciting enough for me personally just
guy girl just 5 side pouring water over
12 is a long and durable resistant to
tears drapes well herself wrinkle
resistant her Nana is a type of 12 in
jeans the smoother size as the front
typically the vertical warp yarns are
dyed blue and the west yarn is left
natural there you go
see if it didn't have a better one for
you I'd be much more bored yeah we have
a little bit of denim is the right way
to go I feel about this
I know one Republic chick ran born today
I'm going to do a urine enema for the
first time oh the first time oh man we
met her before she drinks her pee to
help her fight colds yeah she does we
always we've shown her doing it before
mm-hmm she looks better day during the
day I have collected my urine and I just
poured one quart into my enema bucket
I suppose me Oh neat neat she does
actually look really wait a minute this
chick has a patreon account
yeah for what what it should go in are
we yeah was just her giving herself
around on my left side okay I'm going to
hold it for about five minutes I think I
wanted to do this video just to document
my experience because I'm expecting you
know maybe to be enlightened or kind of
spiritual experience and I wanted to
have it my camera well I feel like we
did her with a coffee enema yeah oh yeah
yeah and she was like I'm holding it in
it's a little painful right now I'm
loving this I want our kids fucking
pulling on a snake pulling his leg okay
let's go back to the pee lady this is
hilarious she's going to get enlightened
by putting piss in her ass I'm going to
lay on my left
I'm going to hold it for about five
minutes go wrong so just to document my
experience so right now I'm just taking
some coconut oil and I'm going to
lubricate she's so crazy I'm also going
to lubricate my mom end oh that's right
she said bottom end on the coffee she's
it's weird how she's picky about certain
words but she's putting piss up her butt
and her asshole okay I love that about
to insert the novel right now
yeah nice been making why is she couple
deep breath she's not really into
torturing herself this broad okay so
it's a top it I'm going to allow me
urine to enter my colon viewing this I'm
going to try to hold it for about five
minutes okay I'm opening the clamp now
why are you doing this to yourself I've
been to mass never you okay hardly
noticing what does she know the thing
how horrible this feels remember I was
gonna try to get someone to piss on my
balls you know what how long 4-minute
just remember when LGI's again but
remember when LJ and I were riding the
train in the mall yeah that was four
minutes as a long time it's an eternity
to hold piss in your asshole dude you
know how much it hurts to have it have
you ever had like anything pushed up
your butt like an animai or anything
one time I put a suppository in my butt
just that suppository it's not fun dude
it fucking hurts this chick is crazy
opening the clamp again ah can't put P
up there and just wrong with this person
I'm having a little bit of leakage and I
don't I don't know why because
leaking out its from the pissing around
a little bit
stop doing that stop it
this chick likes to hurt her say I'm
going to open the clamp for more time no
please don't you know what I was we
should add starting to have this purple
vision um that's drugs no go to her
patron account please donate and and
then right keep putting piss up your ass
keep setting up your own asshole reign
Florence now here's the thing though
jeans pretty to build and more people
would coming together you know what
though when you put something up your
bum it absorbs immediately into your
bloodstream you know that right so I
don't even know if it's okay to put
urine in your bunghole because then
there's toxins in urine that are going
right into her bloodstream but there's a
reason it's waste I just picked up on
something that I was not expecting and
that is what she said right now we might
look be looking at the solution this
country needs this might be the Martin
Luther King jr. of this era and don't
attack me for saying so what I want to
point out is that when she pissed on her
own ass yeah she had a vision of all of
us coming together oh wow maybe Tim
bailed and more people coming together
oh this in response to Charlottesville
and support record of me oh you're 84 Oh
I mean maybe this is the answer to this
just divide in our country right now is
what if we all did urine enemas two
really thought-provoking
suggestion and what if somebody like
Donald Trump said it what if our
projects right I want you to take an
enema I want you to put it in your ass I
want you to piss in it pee in your butt
and in your own butt led by rain
Florence rain try to
because tremendous feelings she felt so
good Democrats and Republicans and
independents alike
I'm opening the clamp again oh oh my
goodness I'm gonna know I want to cry
Wow geez
well maybe we should give this a try
think so I'm having a little bit of
sensation and my buttocks reason region
yeah those are talks it might be because
they the urine is a little bit cold
there might be other reasons are there
any health benefits to putting urine in
your in your bum oh no this was a follow
up on this and somewhere this is
enlightenment
what a psycho yeah and I can't kinds a
crazy it can't be medically found no I
mean it's waste you're essentially
putting it's like putting poo okay it
would be like taking a shit and then
making the shit liquid and then putting
the shit up your own but that's kind of
I mean urine is waste it is waste it's
not as toxic and horrific for you as
shit should now you can drink your own
urine if you let it sit it'll separate
and then you can drink the clearer part
of it I read that in the book oh no you
should drink all of it you're going to
die dude it's delicious yeah we also had
an email from Dan when he what he has to
say
of course mommies I just wanted to let
you know I am had my third dump of the
day already and it's only 12:30 p.m.
normally I poop once or twice a day I'm
wondering do you think this is could be
a side effect of over-hydration
wondering if this ever happens to Tom in
particular Keys use water champ top dog
goes by swiping it as well Dan from San
Jose look at Christina trying to show
off in the homestretch it doesn't count
I think it's an indicative of yes your
water intake could be something and
fiber
don't forget fiber or an irritation now
you didn't tell us what number you're
taking is it loosey-goosey are we
talking you know is it is it a little
bit of a slider what is it yeah we don't
know details anymore major brown but I
would feel 3 by 12 30s a lot that's
pretty aggressive sounds sick I mean who
knows if he sent another email after
that it was like oh it's 6 p.m. I've
taken section and you have diarrhea the
phone thank you
this guy could be just sick so Christina
shot a special in June Samantha there
and you know she'll have an announcement
about it soon in the lead up to it she's
been doing a lot of press getting things
ready for it to come out I don't want to
can you hear is Christina talking about
her news the last sight of this show
everybody it's a blizzard
yeah we'll be fine for a blizzard yeah
you got an ear bead hey the dude with
the cameras scared ooh mad column with
column maybe they'll get out of here
we're excited Barry
my hair is a little Duggar yeah yeah and
that's a different outfit than I need to
see you in net do you comprehend I moved
from California
well oh you don't know I'm from
California and mm as well my parents
gave me this house and my son wanted is
all I brought him a dog why well I think
what do you think's going on with her
sorry what were you thinking there are
you telling this guy about your dog well
I mean look I was excited about special
I had a little too many to celebrate and
I was trying to give you an interview
and didn't come out it's not like some
pit bull dogs run around
and that little girl will be in the
hospital tonight but it looks like she's
going to be okay as far as any charges
or anything nothing's pending at this
point there still needs to be further
investigation and this is actually the
homeowner we're going to talk we're
going to talk to back to you in the
studio Randy I want to ask you
he's a pro he held it together yeah yeah
it's like a heckler it's like when
you're doing your show and some drunk
assholes trying to sabotage your name
find any report on any dogs being loose
from my house or being loose and running
around or have there is once there was a
dog fight I got rid of it one dog along
with winning the whistle the let's go
blow the whistle no he does need the
whistle yeah the dog whistle they should
win loser dog yeah yeah use the code
word mom should get that quick can you
find her you think and tell her about it
here's and let's know this is you this
is you I moved from California sure you
are how's that not you I didn't say it
wasn't
yeah I told you I had a little too much
too much to drink that happens but I
shouldn't I shouldn't talk to that guy I
know that that happens um see blow the
whistle do-do-do-do-do-do oh the whistle
let's see I know where our dogs out are
right now because of the whistle by the
way ball
doo doo doo why did you do that I know I
don't have you now we're done why is how
funny we're done it spawned and we're
all mood I own trust family
I'm a nice one to do my headphones back
on come on no I'll take it down
no you won't yeah take it down take a
wet down the Clipper down over
dun-dun-dun trust you I promise it's
over I promise
nope yeah
they're not listening I took it off
mm-hmm I took I put the asian guy on
from the train earlier he's back up Wow
we went to a restaurant and I had them
bring you a slice of birthday cake and
you got really you trick yeah you did it
when I was in the bathroom you know I
try to avoid as much sugar as I can yeah
but this cake is special this place
where we go they have a fantastic cake
and you don't want to miss out on you
have to add the whole thing it's hard to
resist but anyways it did say happy
birthday and had a candle in it I was
like you got so mad why do you hate that
so much I don't know I don't like it
I don't like it you don't like people
singing to you happy birthday or don't
like the attention that it draws it's
not interesting but you all you do is
get attention for a living but I like it
in that moment I like it when I'm
onstage you can control the attention I
don't like attention offstage right I
don't need to get a bunch of attention
when I walk into a room okay
all right how about being do you like
you when they sing happy birthday no I
do not I don't like surprise parties
I like being sung to I don't like a big
I don't like a big reception like if I
walk into a place I don't like everybody
to say something - I don't like that you
want to be like norm from Cheers
no I like to fly under the radar now
it's true you're kind of low-key guy
yeah interesting I like people to pay
attention when I'm up there and that's
it yeah I agree
some more yeah I don't mind a happy
birthday it's embarrassing
yeah the year you know but I've got a
great personality
here's more festive and more fun too
so you just conceded that I'm more fun
and more festive and therefore a
personality jam think you look good
there's a good case for that um oh my
god just admitted to that case you are
yeah yeah if I put these on and I hear
barf
you're not we're gonna wrap up we got to
wrap up we got to wrap up um don't
question thank you guys for listening
we're going to have some guests coming
up in the next few weeks should be a lot
of fun and I don't know I think that's
head Jean that's it we've got a snake in
our yard we have to take care of steak
we're gonna get these fucking headphones
fixed I don't be so mad that we'll get
taken care of here is the 409 remix Lady
Luck by Chris it's just Chris or does
their laughing here Chris fence Chris
pence thanks very much
that's it gene I love you mommy
nothing but it's not creating
coordinates for the people on account he
wanted for a civil war in this country
[Music]
Oh
luckily